Oh need help sir Oh officer hi need help  no no I'm fine thank you what you got  there pecans I delivering pecans to my  niece in Syria yeah because she makes it  worst pecan pie you've ever tasted I  feel sorry for her husband but and if  you're sorry because  family's the most important thing  don't do what I did I could work in  front of family I thought it was more  important to be somebody out there then  the dam failure was in my own home  [Music]  was a terrible father  terrible husband  blew my chance  [Music]  I didn't deserve forgiveness  this is the last one  so help me God  this is the last one  so what it's worth I'm sorry for  everything  [Music]  [Music]